nous avions toujours pensé que la vie
extra terrestre viendrait des étoiles
mais elle a surgit des profondeurs de
l'océan
le premier kaiju était sorti de l'eau à
san francisco
la deuxième attaque avait frappé manille
puis la troisième frappe à cabo nous
avons compris que ça ne s'arrêterait pas
pour combattre des monstres
nous avons créé nos propres monstres
et nous fallait une nouvelle arme le
programme rigueur était né
deux pilotes nos cerveaux nos souvenirs
connecté
et l'homme et la machine ne font plus
qu'un
aujourd'hui aux limites de l'espoir
autre temps
ont choisi de croire les uns
nous affrontons les monstres qui sont à
notre porte
aujourd'hui nous neutralisons
l'apocalypse
ça c'est drôlement coup
pacific rim